hey everybody welcome to Fantasy Valley
played for as I promised in this video
we're going to be working on the other
side of the Main Street and I'm not
going to be cutting out any of the
buildings in this video I will still cut
out some of the more boring bits
especially doing them that backstage
stuff that I still have to do by adding
the gray walls in all of the gray roofs
and the ACS and H of X and all that but
pretty much every facade that you
actually see from the pike itself and
all of the detailing on the Main Street
is going to be done in this one episode
so the first thing that I wanted to do
is get kind of a counterweight to the
building that I had on the right side
already and what I had as a plan for
quite a while here was to get another
very similar dome basically just copy
over the dome but different textures and
colors on it and make this treat very
symmetrical in that sense have two domes
on two corners and have like the two
central towers all the way at the end of
that street as you look onto the Main
Street but I didn't end up really going
with that plan and instead I want to
make it look a bit more asymmetrical and
a bit more playful so we're going to go
with a castle on this side or at least
the castle inspired building it's mostly
inspired by fear in Palace in Germany
excuse my pronunciation but um it's
basically this beautiful palace
somewhere in northern Germany supposedly
it has the nickname to be the northern
noise one Stein which if you don't know
is the castle that inspired the Disney
looted Castle so getting some
inspiration from good places there and
while it definitely won't be similar in
any kind of structural way and it still
has a different colour scheme I'm hoping
to go for that sort of same general
atmosphere to it with a lot of the
emphasis on very large towers on the
corner of the building because I really
needed something of a large castle tower
on the corner here to sort of give the
counterweight to the very large and like
central dome of the building on the
other side so we have the dome on one
side and we have the tower on the other
side and the rest of it is all just
really playing with a lot of detail and
whatever else I wanted to do with this
building
it's going to be quite a large building
I think it will be the largest building
on the entire Main Street not counting
the entrance building and it will have
quite a few towers on it but I didn't
want to keep it somewhat modest since
this is obviously not going to be the
big castle in the park and it shouldn't
draw too much attention so while it
definitely has some of the typical big
fantasy castle things to it I still
wanted to keep it quite simple so that
you could still fit into the main street
and yeah that's why I figured I would do
it this way with very simple walls and
most of the details and the excellent
really on the towers on the corners of
all of those walls and especially in
this building having that tracker of
keeping the walls apart all the way at
the side there and just making a couple
of different versions of that with
different heights and details on it it
really helped to save a lot of time on
this building it was built in a shorter
time than I really imagined it would
take so I'm quite happy with how that
worked out but it definitely is very
similar on all of the different sides so
um the towers also kind of helped to get
rid of that sort of repetitive look to
the building now obviously since this is
also a Main Street while not very
obviously but since this is a main
street and this Tower does have some
sort of bronze facade which I wanted to
get a store into I also wanted the
building to open up a little bit and
like many castles they have these very
long tall vertical walls but nothing
that really invites you into the
building on all sides I really wanted
some sort of very large balcony that
would go around the corner of the
building so that's what I'm working on
the bottom there and which I'll return
to in a little bit right now which is
going to be like the biggest sort of
bronze part of the building is quite
similar actually to what you see on many
of them many yeah many of the may Street
USA buildings actually have that as well
that why that sticks out and has these
arches which just makes the building a
bit more inviting and I'm working on
that
right here which is basically a
combination of a bunch of different
objects nothing too special
but definitely also a good way to get
some different colors in here I was
hoping that with very wide collars on
these arches it would stick out quite a
lot and also get some different colors
into the building because the the
accents and the color of the walls are
all quite similar on the building so
without all of the white here it doesn't
have too many different colors on it so
it's quite happy with how that turned
out as well and that basically more or
less finishes the front like archways
and the rest of the work that I still
wanted to do was a bit of final details
to make it look like it's actually
finished I think this might also be a
very good building to turn into a
blueprint at some point and actually
have details all around it but since
this is for the main street it's not
going to be like a forecastle and it'll
really only be the front facade of it
and the parts that you can actually see
from the parts that I'll really work on
that the rest will just be backstage
stuff basically in our one final tower
over here
because this is going to be another
corner because the building next to this
is gonna sit back into the wall quite a
bit with a small balcony to make that
look a bit more inviting as well is more
or less what finishes of the shape of
the building I actually think this is
the second to last tower yeah this is
the second to last hour the last tower
we'll get into in a little bit which
should hopefully finish and round off
the building on the other side as well
which is for me personally it's also
quite important since I have no idea how
I'm actually gonna transition from the
Main Street into the other areas of the
park and I will still have to work on
that at some point in the future and I'm
not really sure if I'll have just like a
simple sort of transitioning area
without any buildings or if I'll do it
very phantasialand is one of the things
which I love about phantasialand is just
how compact the park is and just every
single available square metre is just
filled to the brim with all kinds of
scenery and there are no like to the
transition areas as you would have in
Disney so whether I'll have the
transition areas or not I'm not really
sure yet so I'm hoping to close off
these buildings and make sure that
they're gonna be working whatever way
I'll be working the pathways around them
and finally of course I did want to put
something inside this building since it
is quite a very a current building and
as much as I kind of wanted to put the
shop which is a cheap beef shop right
here as much as I wanted to put that in
the front in like the diagonal part
where you would usually see the entrance
of a building like this it just doesn't
really work out with having that round
Tower and I definitely wanted the round
tower to run all the way to the end so
it's on the side here but I'm trying to
at least make the facades on the side as
open as I can so that's why there are
chief beep signs around the entire
building to kind of make it look like
it's a restaurant where you could
possibly get in on all sides and quite a
lot of foliage should make that look a
bit more inviting as well and that more
or less finishes of the bottom of this
building and I think that is almost it
for this building as well and it's about
time to move on to the next one after I
copy over a couple of these lumps which
I might get back to in the future I
might put some hanging baskets with
flowers on these limbs we'll see about
that now on to the next building which
is going to be an Alpine building which
is quite funny I was while really
doubting if I wanted to do this for
quite a while since I already have an
Alpine building almost well directly I'm
in front of this building on the other
side of the main street and they are
going to be pretty similar so it's it's
not the most different thing and I was
really trying to make like all of the
buildings on this side of the Main
Street kind of like different variations
of the buildings that I already have on
the other side but this is maybe a bit
too similar so we're gonna throw in some
other fun stuff on this building and one
of the things which I wanted to try it
is have a porch in front of it with like
vines and lot of bushes on top of that
to kind of make this natural
yeah natural kind of bush roof on the
front of this building and this is going
to be the toilet building because I'm
putting toilets in all of my Alpine
buildings in this Pike so far so we're
going to keep that rolling and yeah the
approach otherwise is quite simple which
I always do love about Alpine buildings
they are quite simple to do if you kind
of get the hang of them they never
really have to complicated shapes or
anything it's just a lot of white stucco
balls with the wooden framing on top of
it and that usually just finishes it off
with a overhanging roof and that's
pretty much good in all cases so I'm
following the same theme here but I was
using the blanks kind of like sunken
into the wall because they're a little
bit less thick than the pillars and the
regular use of the planks and I'm quite
happy with how that looks as well you
can just fit in a few more planks and a
bit more detail if you make the planks a
bit smaller that way I'm just adding a
bit of foliage there with some vines on
the side and a few of those hanging
bushes to kind of make it look like
they're really climbing up the pillars
for a little bit and pulling down from
the ceiling in a way and quite happy
with how that foliage thing works in a
way having those like the overgrowth of
vines and bushes all over building is
very short and easy way to make sure
that it's going to be looking like a
charming building but we're already
moving on to the next one which is going
to be a slightly castle themed building
again very similar to the building on
the other side but this one will
definitely have a different color scheme
and different kind of details on it so
even though it's the same general idea
it should hopefully be able to stand on
its own quite well and the first thing
that I wanted to do here is be a bit
more playful with the general layout of
the building than the one on the other
side the other one building is just like
a straight facade with straight walls
and a gallery underneath that and this
one at least has a bit of an elf
footprint to it to make one part stick
out a bit more and have part of the
unite
kaleri way which I have underneath it
also sort of support a balcony on the
first floor so we're having that
and also I wanted to go with a dome on
top of this building instead of a tower
which is quite funny in a way as well
because if you look like from the lake
at the main street you'll be seeing a
tower basically from left to right
you'll be seeing a tower and then a dome
and then a tower
and from right to left you'd be seeing a
dome and then a tower and then it's our
which sounds like it's [ __ ] and
nothing really important but I had that
dome on the right side and I just wanted
to feature one in one of the buildings
on the left side as well so that's what
we're going for here and it's just one
of these standard ingame domes but I
added those quick black trims on it
which actually quite like I think one of
the things which I really love about
those stone pieces is even though
they're not very versatile and at least
as of now they're not recolor abour you
can like mix them with so many different
pieces to create very unique domes or
towers that's what I had a little bit of
an experiment with here and that's
definitely a piece which I'm gonna use
quite a bit more in the future
but yeah one thing which I also wanted
to do with this building is get a few
more interesting colors in here so far
this side of the Main Street doesn't
really have much of the bright colors
which the other side of the Main Street
already does have so I want to take that
green color and not just have it come
back in the color of the dome but also
have it come back in the color of the
windows and some of the accents which
right now might be looking like it's not
the best idea while I'm doing all of
these beige accents corner stones and
trims on the building itself to make
sure that it's all ready to add the
windows and other details but it's
actually something which I'm quite happy
with in hindsight I didn't plan to do it
all the time but um as soon as I got
those windows in and they're pretty much
just the same color as the other accents
I think it was quite a good idea to add
windows with a different colour as well
now I was still struggling with the
dormers for a bit to be honest I think
there isn't really a good choice in
dormers in the game so far there are
just a few of them and men
give them don't really fit into anything
that easily and what I might just do in
the future to make my life a bit easier
to just make blueprint domes or
blueprint dormers the blueprint domes is
actually pretty good idea as well and
just get a bunch of different styles
that I would like to use more often in
as like blueprints because having to
make all of these separate dormers can
be pretty time-consuming and as much as
I do like the current ones in the game
they're not as versatile and not really
usable on all of the styles that I would
like them to be usable in but yeah one
of the other things which I wanted to
get into of course are the windows on
this building and I wasn't really sure
how many of the windows I really wanted
to burn the end I ended up with having
two in the front there and two in the
back with like slightly different
distances between them which is a little
bit awkward but I kind of do like the
effects and the way that it looks in the
end and slightly more simple windows on
the tower and that should finish off
basically the rest of the building and
finally I wanted to do what I can't stop
doing and I might want to stop doing
this at some point in the future because
I am definitely going to overuse those
pieces
adding those roof pieces the the golden
roof trims on top of the roof here which
is just I know I use it a lot it's just
something which I really love and I've
tried some different fences on top of
the roofs to get the same kind of effect
but none of them really have that golden
texture and well an almost fantasy feel
to it either that this one has another
final touches and details to make the
building come alive as you can see it is
now a cosmic cow milk shake shop and I'm
adding a bunch of window boxes to add a
bit of foliage to the building make it
look a bit more inviting and that more
or less finishes this building and I
think it's time to move on to the next
one alright so the next building is
going to be one very small and simple
building and it's it's kind of like the
counterpart of the very small and simple
building on the other side as well just
two squares wide and a very simple hip
roof and a very simple corner
underneath it as well I'm just plopping
some random windows on it I have to be
honest this is pretty much just a fellow
building in every sense of the word I
just needed to get this space filled up
and to get three buildings in this would
have been way too tight but to get one
building in this space wouldn't really
fit since it would be way too large of a
building so I'm just getting this very
small building into this corner so that
we can work on the next building which
is gonna catch a bit more attention it's
gonna be a bit larger and in a style
which I haven't really done so far in
the park and he'll which I haven't
really done that often at all we're
gonna be building a quick English Tudor
kind of townhouse on this side here with
like some dough is very dark brown
archways underneath it and on the real
Tudor part with all of the frame work
we're gonna have some white stucco and
black framework which is gonna be very
dense and have all of these large roof
shapes on top of it as well so I'm
getting the gallery in there I'm playing
with the roof for a little bit I figured
it would be best to get that steep roof
in all the way since it has that very
steep sort of curved angle that I wanted
to go for and make a bit of a custom
dormer kind of roof gable that sticks
out on the front to get some windows
that really pop out of the building and
that's basically the general shape of it
it's pretty flat building but it's still
made out of two separate buildings to be
able to have there the forms that comes
out a bit more than rest of the building
and the rest of the framework is just
again it's very easy to do and I haven't
really looked up any kind of Tudor
references I might have missed some like
typical to the framing and done some
things wrong in this case which if I did
always feel free to call me out on it um
but I was just kind of going for the
general Tudor kind of atmosphere in this
case which meant a lot of very very
dense frame work much more dense than I
have with all of the Alpine building so
far the black colour in there and some
of the very gothic looking windows as
well and I've tried
but it doesn't really work outs to get
some of those to the frame works in
there because to the frameworks they
often have curves and like very specific
kind of details like to the roses in
them and it practically impossible to
really do that there's probably a way to
do it but in this case I couldn't really
be bothered to try it so I just got a
few very simple diamonds in there almost
like there is actually to the roses and
the rest of the building is just low
very heavy dense framework and that
should finish that off quite nicely and
I think I remember making this yeah this
is the information kind of building
since it is right at the entrance and
it's not the most like visible thing
like burgers or milkshakes which you
want to have as visible as you can
because you do need to make a buck out
of them and well that's how capitalism
works but we can get a bit of an
information thing in here close to the
entrance and not too much in in the line
of sight but still in a way that you can
I quickly go to as you get into the park
so very quick information booth in here
should finish off the may treat and
final things that I wanted to do is to
get in a few of these planters that I
have on the other side trying to make
all of the paths work as symmetrical as
I can and a bunch of scenery over here
as well pretty much in the same way as
the other side a few barrels here a few
like pots and urns there and a whole
bunch of planters and that should finish
off the Main Street so that's it for
today thank you guys for watching and
I'll leave you with some cinematic shots
[Music]
[Music]